[Music]
oh that was good that's better than
ass I I like that compion is pretty good
they
know that was dope um we'll just get
stuck straight into it if you can
because we've got 15 minutes and I feel
us it's going to go quite quickly so can
I throw the first question jump in man
cool right so um it's me first shut up M
um so Star Trek has shown us that
keeping Cannon straight is actually
quite hard apparently and Star Wars at
times Stargate was always really good at
it though and I always we always talk
about how keeping the cannon was always
really good in Stargate there's not many
times I think he made
mistakes um how did you keep it all
straight you know setting all these
rules up and things and was there any
times that you can think of that it
nearly went horribly wrong or
actually the the first time it went
horribly horribly wrong was in the
opening scene of the pilot but I've told
that story uh uh through and and then
step back and we went he can't do that
and so that you know we fixed it sort of
not really
um the reason the reason we were pretty
good at continuity is because we had a a
team of writers and
directors that had a
so enjoyed working together that we just
stayed for the longest time I mean I
left this this I don't know of many
cases if any where this has happened
before but I left the show for a bit and
came back like I came and went and
because I needed to recharge and and
spent more than a few days with my
family and but I came back and it was oh
hey Brad come back in and I would always
spin stories and because it was me Rob
for the you know almost the entire show
Rob came on as a story edit early early
early on I think we were shooting the
pilot so he from the
beginning
um and so there's that continuity and
then and then Paul and Joe came on in
season 4 and so somebody basically would
just raise their hand Whenever there was
an issue Whenever there was like oh wait
a minute can't do that you know and
sometimes we would go have we broken
that is that a rule can we do that and
then we'd say sure and so that's when
you create new Cannon because you're not
contradicting anything um but I think it
was just the continuity of um the
continuity of of uh writers and
directors because on set occasionally
somebody a director would say well let's
try this and you know somebody would say
that you can't do that with a staff
weapon you know it doesn't work that way
it just does this and uh and and so that
was very helpful just the rules of going
back and forth through a Stargate is
it's really handy when everybody knows
what those rules are and and you don't
have to explain it to this to a new
director because time is money in that
situation yeah I mean even when you went
over to SG Atlantis and then SGU it was
sort of an extension of that team it
always felt it was you knew it was you
know you watch the crew and it was like
I know him from
there Rob and I st both stepped back in
the last two years of Atlantis uh a
little bit uh I mean I came I kept
coming in and helped break stories and I
wrote a couple I think um the shrine
happened in a year that I that I wasn't
uh on fully but that was also to help
free some time to develop and come up
with something new because MGM was
saying we're going to need what the next
thing is and and uh for whatever reason
Atlantis had a hard time um in terms of
the business model going Beyond season
five I I that was a f you know that was
a business model issue more than
anything else MGM was imploding at the
time there always I mean well they were
I know that it was scary it was scary
and and when they did implode it was It
was kind of heartbreaking because people
I knew were people I had talked to for
years and I would phone and it would be
so and so no longer works at MGM and
You' go oh do you have a number so and
so no longer works at MGM that's all
they would
say um and uh so yeah it was kind of sad
and and of course we saw it coming the
last season of universe and it was like
the Titanic heading toward the iceberg
he was like oh we're going to hit
that
Iceberg there's no way around it it was
it was a slow motion Perfect Storm well
it was heartbreaking for fans when it
happened it was uh and now MGM basically
doesn't
exist I mean they certainly do exist as
a brand and as a library uh um and there
are people who work at MGM now now uh
some of them have even some of even the
new people who I met to when they asked
me to ride a pilot have moved on so um
uh but MGM is one of the most
recognizable brands in the world to this
day uh so that's you know when when
Amazon buys something it's more than
just a library it's it's that line yeah
I saw my first movie last night that was
MGM um it's so called killing something
it's quite good actually but it was
Amazon MGM Studios really first one I've
seen yeah interesting interesting it was
a moment I had to pause it like that's a
moment need to remember that but anyway
Matt do you wan to jump in I do I
do oh I'm sorry we're out of time no I'm
kidding you wouldn't stopping reach you
the screen and grab you if you
tried you mentioned starget Universe
there um which is probably my favorite
of the three um how much of a plan was
there for Stargate Universe um how much
can you tell us about where they would
have gone had you it all it all had to
do ultimately with with the mystery and
the and the Destiny's original Mission
and and rush and and twin Destinies in
the second um I mean that was intended
to launch a whole new arc um because at
the end of twin
Destinies the crew basically get sent to
another timeline
and and and and we're going to
create as we see in epilog and and
Beyond a whole a whole bunch of humans
that we could run into uh who would join
in our Quest um and help you know keep
the destiny afloat and alive and going
and uh the transition was
always supposed to be and I think one of
the problems with the show is we took
too long to do this it was supposed to
be the wrong people in in on the ship
like totally this these people are not
supposed to be here and and and then
jelling over the course of a period of
time to become exactly the right people
to do the
mission and and uh and that mission
ultimately was to find out um the the uh
what the Ancients perceived as uh as
something that evidence of an intellig
that existed before the Big
Bang um which which had some spiritual
uh uh impact on some people but but also
a science point of view U and then of
course the other fun thing about that
is um uh the Ancients clearly figured
that out or they would have or or they
would have gone to Destiny they launched
the ship hoping to do this and then went
oh we got it probably because they
ascended it was because they ascended
yeah but but we haven't ascended and so
the the the idea of the human humankind
taking over that mantle for our own
purposes I I thought was always really
interesting what you have had um so you
mentioned the descendants of the the
original cre went back in time would you
have had those join Destiny at some
point well we we certainly already
encountered them and I and because they
moved on from that planet uh I had hope
that we would see seeds of them uh
elsewhere in the in the next galaxy when
we arve there G Eli was going to fix the
ship and and we and we were going to
emerge into a Galaxy where there were
also humans and they were our own
descendants which is kind of cool I just
thought that was really cool nice I
remember the moment pitching when I
pitched that idea on the phone I was in
Arizona for some reason I was on on the
phone with Robert and and uh and Paul
and Joe and they went cool we can shoot
humans because I was always objecting to
the fact that if we're a million
galaxies away why do we have why why
would we run into humanoids that's why
everybody was so alien when we met
them the main question we got when we
asked this out to fans was will we get a
conclusion SGU will we get and it's the
question I know you obviously we with no
way of knowing but it is probably the
most thing we're asked you know me I get
asked a lot to
uh and and whoever takes over the
show may not even want to you know
continue in Canon but if they do I'm
pretty sure they have to answer that
question what what happened yeah there I
have come up with lots of ways uh and in
my pilot uh script address the issue um
oh that's a good way for now you address
the issue that's going to get people
asking questions well I don't want to
say what I did because whoever does it
might want to do do something like that
and I don't want to I don't want to put
it out there I mean in some ways it's
kind of an obvious
solution put it in your Memoir tell us
in your Memoir maybe yeah I'll put it in
my Memoir Jay as long as you get it out
your some point I can't write a memoir
because I don't remember enough be I
don't know I was working it's a I can
tell you about what happened at my kid's
birthday party that year but I can't the
show is a blur doing 22 or episodes that
must have just been I mean I hate
stories about you know writing literally
writing and then filming next day and
things like this and just that it was
just we we were actually pretty good at
staying ahead I I was I was
uh I was a big big believer of giving
the crew and still am a big believer in
giving the crew time to prep a script
because you can't build the sets we were
building uh with a script that you get
you know during prep you I was
developing story ideas with the art
Department I wouldn't just I would the
so a writer would say what did we do
this this and this and I would go down
to the art department or for that matter
go down to the visual effects department
and say can we do this if we do this
let's consider doing this and then we
that would be too expensive and so he
would say okay well let's build this for
this show but be able to repurpose the
structure for this show and you probably
for the most part don't even didn't even
know what we had done that but but
preparation in producing as a right of
prod uh puts money on the screen uh and
and keeps your crew alive uh having said
that your lead way goes away right you
start with 10 scripts or however many
scripts and you think they're in great
shape but then when you read them when
you okay time to do a pass on this
script you go oh I have to rewrite
this thing completely and it has
generally less to do with the with the
me mechanism of the show the mechanics
of the show than it does just the
characters and the dialogue there's a
there's a ton of Stargates where I
remember writing scenes and I'll see it
I go I remember writing that scene and
then the episode will the credit will
happen or I'll go back and see what the
credit was oh I I guess I didn't write
that one or I did but my name isn't not
it job is to rewrite and make sure that
the characters all have the same voices
and and and for production and something
you think will be a great script at the
beginning of prep isn't necessarily
going to work by the time you're in
August and you don't have the money you
thought you
would I think it was actually Star Trek
I was thinking about that they were I
heard stories about them literally
writing scripts the day before and then
sending him off I'm watching Brent
Spiner saying I got script one night and
you were filming the next day and he was
like I'm supposed to learn 30 pages and
like you know mad no happens and
and and I I've been in the situation
where I've had to write for the next day
I mean you know an actor gets a pentis
or something you have to you have to
make changes you have to
you have to make changes on the on the
fly or one of your actors fall over us
and hurts his ankle or something who
knows yeah these things happen um we
wanted to ask a question that sort of
get a feeling of of a bit more about you
and what sort of thing you still watch
now so if you got the if you got the
chance to write an episode for something
that was on TV now or sci-fi or anything
really what sort of show do you think
what would you love to like oh I'd love
to write an episode for that
well that's not really a fair question
because I think you know the answer is
Star Trek uh I I got into this business
I got into this business uh in part so I
could write for Next
Generation and I really wanted to write
for that show I thought it was the best
show on TV and and uh so when Tera
metalis did season three of a card I was
so jealous because I thought that ship
had sailed and then I told him so I I I
I sent him a message and said man you
just did my dream and and you did it
really great you did it better than I
would have so congratulations but yeah
if if anybody asked me to write in I
don't care which Star Trek I like them
all I I would do that in a heartbeat
it's not gonna happen but I would do
it it's not gonna happen because you
don't bring in somebody from the outside
uh as a freelancer anymore that just
doesn't happen anymore it used to but it
doesn't
anymore two minutes mat are gone
two so
I got the question other than z z nicel
with the three shot rule is there any
other part of Stargate law that you
would have Recon in
hindsight
probably honestly there's a bunch of
stuff uh that that
just you know you you you
uh you R we ran through a lot of trees
you know because you you think you write
exterior and you have to you can't shoot
everything in the studio but you know
it's it's
just
uh at the end of the day I mean and and
I wish I wish I could remove a couple of
episodes just from the show like wow
like emancipation is terrible we don't
want it's terrible I know it is I'm not
dumb I knew then I was like oh this is
gonna kill us but um it it it's you
can't you can't rewrite history i' I've
done a series about that too by the way
uh and uh but you can't do it in I love
Travelers Travelers is one myv shows I
I'm very proud of it it's a good show I
love that nobody noticed that the Z
looks like a penis you just didn't
realize that yeah nobody noticed no it
never occurred to me until Michael
Shanks told us thing we got
two no we got two really quick fire
questions from fans so one t bat asked
us um how's your handicap these days uh
it's down to a 13 index that's not bad
that's pretty good that's pretty good I
shot 82 yesterday oh that's very good
that's pretty good mine's rubish like
three or something it's a it's a hard
game man it's a hard game yeah it really
irritates me I hit the ball and it goes
to two o'clock so I think I'll aim over
at 10 o'clock then it still goes to two
o'clock no you just need to adjust your
grip Jay we'll talk about that another
time yeah yeah anyway last one last one
this is from gray gray greyhammer
I think I've said that right um what do
the furlings actually look like we all
have the image in of evil Ewok little
Ewoks but they're not that's yeah okay
sure that's what it is here's here's
how Robert was writing an episode called
the fifth race and he wanted it to be
the fifth race because it sounded cooler
than the fourth race so as he was
listing the things we we okay the knock
okay the you know he he needed another
name and he came up with the furlings
and I remember reading the script I went
furlings who the hell are the furlings
he went I needed another name
that is the extent of of their creation
true story which is why we mocked it so
much in the 200th episode or the 100th
whichever it was so the furlings are
basically whatever we think they look
like sure sure and and if you think that
we sat around going I think the fings
are this or that no no no it was Rob
needed another name and that's what it
was coming up with alien names is not
always easy
and probably regretted that one we said
the fings should be the villains in the
new show when it ever comes out so we we
joke about the evil Ewoks quite a lot I
yeah sure sure okay it's probably not a
very good idea but uh to to make
everybody furry in a in a television
show but those poor
actors yes
exactly you so so much for that
astonishing 15 minutes is not long in a
Florence I hate you right now
well I mean I will lose my voice by the
end of this so you got first at least so
yeah great
to I watch your stuff uh you know more
about uh what's going on at MGM than I
do and I appreciate the Insight so thank
you no thank you that's that's amazing
for to say yeah we've been very very
lucky just stupidly lucky but thank you
so much all right thanks guys see you
all right and